*Mark practicing his popsicle eating skills*  Helelelele
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to "The Visitor Massacre at Camp Happy".
It's not gonna be so happy once we're through with it...
*dies a little inside at his joke* I have terrible jokes...
So after I got done playing "Astrocreep" which I'm sure you all watched because you all love me so much and watch all of my videos (and have a shrine- wait, what?)
Right?? Because they're so full of "Good Jokes™"!!
anyway
So I got all reminescent and
I discovered that The Visitor has another game
and judging by what I've seen from it, it's not the same as before-
it is NOT
a point and click style adventure game.
It is just a little bit different.
You actually are FREE
to roam about the woods and
killeughhh-Hello
*delectable Mark noise*
I-I miss the visitor very much because it's
a horrifying
penile-like creature.
"Looks like a great night to watch the meteor showers."
"We should trek up the mountain to get a better view. Are you coming Stacey?"
"No thanks, Brian, I'd rather stay here safe in the tent."
"There's no WAY any of those alien creatures will crawl up my butthole in this tent!" (Keep telling yourself that)
"It's gonna be the sure fire way to stay alive in the woods!~" (Uh-huh, sure)
"The animals are more scared of you than you are of them."
"Just the same Steve, we should stick to the trails. Who knows what's lurking out there in the darkness?"
Oh, I think we all know what's lurking out there in the darkness (Sunshine and rainbows, right?)
HHOORRIBLE BUTT-MUNCHIN' MONSTERS!
SO! *The whumpage begins* Welcome to-- Ouhh.
Welcome to Camp Happy!
SO! Now that the ominous music has crescendo-ed
What we do is walk around and then press space to eat...
Oh okay.
Heehh
OHHHH OHAHAHAHOO
You think-- Oh
Whe-- I'm gon getcha. I'mmo getcha, you squirrel-bitch!
Don't you know what I'm a King of?! You!
Godammit.
Get-- Get back here! Stop-- OHHH YOU'RE A SASSY SQUIRREL AIN'T CHA?
YOU'RE LUCKY I DON'T KNOW HOW TO PLAY THE GOD-DAMNED GAME.
Okay, so sneak up behind them, that's what the information sai--
HAAAAA!
OHHH GOTCHA! I got little squirrel arms now!
You're done.
I mean you're done obviously but everything else in this entire
forest is d- OWW
Why?
Ouchies!
What am I suppos--Ohhh
*nom* *Markimoo sounds of delight*
Ohhhh
*Giggles* Ohoo
*Giggles* Oohoohoohoo
*Starts laughing*
Oh- HAAAAA!
You can't beat me now- why do I have fins?
It was a turtle.
Why do I have fins?
Hang on a second, that's illogical.
Oh well, I'm not gonna question too much...
Just gonna smear blood all over the place,
maybe I can spell my name
in the blood.
Oh no, it's not enough.
Well, let's assume those are boobs and move on.
Oh, hey buddy.
NNAAGH!
OH... I wasn't supposed to do that.
I'mma getcha BIRDIE
Oh shit
Help, I actually hit my TARGET
YEAH
YEAH EUGHH AH YAH *rekt*
AHHHHH!
I fell
God I'm a terrible alien...
YAH YARG
OHHH, gotcha bitch!
I don't think I was- I don't think I did that the ri- WHAAAA
Well, I'm a big birdie now.
Now no one c-- oh god that
That butthole face (Behold the glory of the butthole face)
Speaking of buttholes-- AARH!
Oh geesh
OH GEEEEEESH...
Those poor mountain lions
Oh those poor cougars
Ooooh wow
Anybody in that tent?
Oh. Oh Stacey, hey Stacey.
Oh... Why is there clothes in a bag?
*Singing voice* Staceeeey, oooh Staceeeeey
Oh, someone's scritch-scratching on your tent here Stacey
Hablughff
Oh God, why do they gotta explode like that?
Human devoured? YEAH!
I got a new highscore on human-eating!
"Hi there. Do you know the way to the mountain trail?"
"Keep heading North and you'll find it.
Although, I've been hearing some strange noises coming from the forest, so you better be carefull"
They conspicuously sound like a creature borrowing into a human anoos
and then exploding 'em from the inside.
I've heard that too many times in my life to mistake it
so trust me, it's bad news.
Alright so---OH
Well I guess this guy is gonna be the victim then.
Poor guy...
He's already dead
*MAXIMUM WHUMPERDRIVE!* WHUUMM
Ok
Why am I small again?
WHA--WHY AM I SMALL?
I guess it would be
less interesting-- oh I gotta sneak up behind
EHHHH
Oh no now they're guarded
HEEEH
Ah don't get me
Aw well now they're guarded. NEYEH
Get back over there!
OOOOOHH GOT ONE!
HOHO
Ah shit, ok, sneak up behind
BE-DOOSH
YEEEAAAH
Ok so
I don't think I'm big enough to eat that boar
uh DOYP HOOOHH
HEYEY
HO OH
HEY
Ok GOODBYE!
So I don't think I'm big enough to eat that just yet
oooh dat little one doe
DAT LITTLE ONE DOE
AW HO poor little guy..
He's dead now
Oh no it bwoke
Wait a minute
How am I gonna be--
EHH
OH HO YOU THINK THAT YOU COULD DEFTLY EVADE
BUT YOU COULD NOT
Ok so now
Aww, but how am I gonna be able to get back?
Do i need to get another animal over here before I can get back-
HEYAH
Ohh you're all fubbernucked now
because I got the swimming skills
Ok so what I need to do is I need to-
Ow, I need to get this guy first
and THEN get that guy
Oh no wait it would've been fine either way, I'm just bigger now..
I'm just girthier
which is exactly what I was hoping for anyway
I SEE YOU IN THERE!
ARRAGHRR
Oh no, am I too heavy for this?
Oh! They respawn!
That turtle was not there before
so there must be another bird here somewhere..
Shake the tree
get the birds all outta here
Where's me a bird
I wanna bird
The mice are back
eh  EHHH EHHOOO
Ah I'm smaller now
Got 'em! OH I'm smaller
That's good!
I'm a smaller fish type
so I've eaten the cougar
I'm small now ho oh
You're in trouble! OH!
*admires his handiwork*
WOW
Ok I did not expect that to go that way but ok
"I think we're heading the wrong way."
And my god those noises they're getting louder
"Hmm, I'm sure this is North. Why don't you two wait here?
I'll just walk up to the ridge by myself
all by my lonesome
with no one to protect me
and watch my butt
LITERALLY
And figure out where we are."
Great plan, Steve (Mark seems not to have faith in Steve :c )
Whatever your name is..
That's a nice bird,
that's a nice bird on that ridge
WHUMP
Don't mind my whumpage
I got a lot of whumpy rocks
and for some reason I'm still coming in from outer space
GERRR
I'mma get you
NEHTH
he he
heh heh heh heh
AHHHH
Aww dang it
hegh bluhh
Well that's not gonna help me because I'm just a small
I'm just as small as I was were before
so that doesn't help me much.
At least now I can swim which is a good feature
Hello?
Excuse me sir
Neh OOWWW
Ok so that's not gonna work
AH HERE WE GO
Swim across here
Get the birdie
Eh get the BIRDIE!
He never saw it coming
So how do I get in there?
Ahhh up here-
Ohh this is a problem for you.
Sorry, you're dead now
Ok so now I should be big enough to take on the boar down below..
Not quite the mountain lion just yet but definitely this boar here
Heh blooskie (such beatiful voice, don't you think?)
Oh yeah,
oh yeah
oh hell yeah
Aww but now I need to fly..
Oh that's no good
Ok, ahh, but here we go I can swim-
swim across here and I need to be able to fly but I can't get to that one just yet
Wasn't there another bird over here?
Uh oh it worked!
Ok, it works, so now I can take on this motherhumper here
HEYAH
Alright, how do I- but how...
The last step is to just get through here
and I'm guessing I have to be small to be able to do that-oops.
To be able to- good thing you had your head down. I mean, not good for you, but good for me.
Oh yeah. Ohhh yeah.
Aaaaand that didn't work but I need to be a scurrrrooorrying- beast?
Oh, but I did become a scurrying beast when I ate YOU! YOU!
Okay. Noo. No! YOU!
Okay, now I am the scurrying beast.
Heh! Heh I'm tiny. Beh! I'm tiny now!
Okay so this- that's actually cool, there's some ga-ahhh.
*relishes in the impending butthole munching*
Ohhh! Oh oh oh oh UP YOUR BUTT! *surprise butt munch*
Uh oh.
Waaaaaah! Mah *giggles at the misfortune of the poor camper* heart.
Lemme just sit dow- *gets surprise butt..... munched* Ooh!
*various Mark noises of pain and possibly slight pleasure*
Need to breathe this one off! Oooh boy!
"Hi Ma'am. Did you happen to see a hiker go past here? Short guy with a beard?
"Sorry, we mermaids don't see a lot around here.
But if he's wondering out alone, you better find him.
There's something roaming around scaring all the animals."
"Also devouring people. Did I mention that?
As a mermaid, I don't need to worry about that. I'm just gonna keep swimming around." (Sure)
"But you guys should watch out."
"That doesn't sound good."
Hmm. Ohh no! I don't want to kill the otters!
The otters are cute! I mean everything else is kinda cute too, but at the same time it's like 'oh no, the otters.'
Okay.
Huh.
So, this is gonna be interesting because
who knows...who knoooows what I'm gonna need throughout this adventure.
Okay.
Ohh but it's too big. Okay.
So...
For size, I need to be flying before I go there.
Oh! Or maybe I can- oh. Maybe I can get back that way.
Owww!
Oh cool, I can. Okay.
Ow! Goddammit, stop playing ping pong with my butt!
Hebuh! Oww! Jeezum, stop it.
I don't wanna die.
Okay. Heyaw.
Got you.
Okay so that- now I'm bigger and I can eat that thing now.
Heh!
Ow! Fuck off! Thank you. *readily devours the cute little otter he was just saying he didn't want to kill a moment ago*
Okay, so now he's dead.
But I need to be smaller now.
Need to be much smaller.
Heeyarg
Maybe this is gonna be small enough? I don't know if this is gonna be small enough.
*self wreckage* Ahh! Okay, not small enough.
So there's gotta be another like, small-
Or may- I need to be a scurrying
I need to eat that squirrel. That's what I need.
Ahh, don't. Don't. Please don't.
Oooh. Aw dammit- BAAAH! Euuugh.
That's pulsating and weird.
Whump! Okay, good thing I got another one.
Ooookay. That was nice, very tasty.
There we go, okay. I needed flying.
So now that I have flying
I would be able to get- yeah, I'd be able to get over this chasm here.
Okay,  now I got it.
And get rekt!
Okay, so now that I got that, I can get the scurrying now
and get small enough to go through the shrubbery..
Over yonder way. Okay! Now I got it!
Lemme just step on the mangled corpse of that cougar there.
And go through here.
Oh, so.... trepidatious-like
Get dat. Mermaid. You better prepare yourself because you're about to be devoured.
So I gotta slip by this turtle here, I can't eat that. Eweweew
Deueugh it's like a maze! It's a wonderful, delightful maze.
Full of fun and friendship and freedom.
Don't mind me. Oh! We're here!
Hello! Uh oh.
Oh, nope, sorry. That's how every horror movie goes.
You die! Anyone that's swimming - instantly dead.
It just goes to show, my fear of the ocean is definitely verified.
"Who's out there? Don't come any closer, I have a knife!"
"Whooa, calm down, smoke a joint. We're just looking for our friend."
"I heard terrible screaming! There's something out there. You two better seek shelter."
"These tents, they're definitely gonna protect us."
"I'm scared Steve."
"Let's just find Brian and get back to the campsite."
How bout you don't, because he's dead.
Oh, that guy is sooo dead. That guy is sooo dead.
Oh, that guy is so dead!
Alright.
Okay.
Ugh, it's right there!
It's sooo close. *delightful accent*
Rawr. Yeah, fuck your camp, bruh.
Ahhh!
Don't kill me!
(sniffles)
Alright, what do we got? Raccoon?
Ow, shit.
Oh, that's a hefty log there. That can hold something big.
Eh, but I don't need to be big.
I don't need to be big yet, anyway.
Least I'm bigger now.
Heeeeee get you!
Ohhh yeah. Okay, so now I can scurry through here.
Oh but that-that's definitely uh...
That's definitely too hefty for me.
So, I can't go through there. So I gotta be a small scurrying beast there.
Oh, dang it. But there's really no way to go after that...
'Cause the hefty log doesn't lead anywhere else...
Oh, no, wait! There's a bunch of bushes up here, how could I miss that?
And another hefty log.
Get big! Oww. Okay, goodbye.
Get small!
Get- get nice and smol.
Haha! Okay, now that I got smol,
I just need to go down over here...
Through the bushes
Through the bushes down here. Go through here..
Now I'm in a new area. I can't eat that, but I can eat you. Owwww.
You and then the turt, grow some fins for some strange reason.
Go across the river...
Go up there...
Sea otter, no. No, please. Nooo.
No no no no no no
Sooo... what else?
Oh! Duh! I just go back around and then I'm suddenly in the ocean again.
Oh perfect! Got h- *nom* wooooowww I went to quick work!
Man, that tent was so flimsy, your head powed right through that shit.
Why'd you think that could protect you??
That wasn't gonna do anything.
"I'm cold and scared."
Ohhhhh, goood for youuuu! (My sensors indicate trace amounts of sarcasm)
Keeeep whining, everyone's dying!!
"We're protected by the mountains. Stay and make a fire."
"I'll hike over the hill and see if I can find help."
Yeah! Split up!
That's the best way to go about these things! (Sarcasm at dangerously non-lethal levels)
Good job, everybody!
Doing great.
Doing so good.
So proud of ya. So proud of ya for surviving for so long. (Ultra sarcasm)
You did it. You really did it.
You did good.
Alright, whommp. Okay.
So, screw you guys. I need that squirrel, like, right away.
That squirrel will never...see me coming!
Ohhh, I got both of ya!!
I got both of ya!
Ngeluh. *Mark laughs*
So, that one's been done. Nothing over there, nothing over there.
Don't mind the moving shrubbery over here.
Okay, so- ahh! Mountain lion!
Okay
So I can't go that way...
I would need flying to be able to go over there.
And I don't think I can get that bird just yet
'cause I don't have any fishy fish.
So there's gotta be some avenue down here that leads to something else.
Eh! Ohhh oh oh.
You got rekt!
Okay, so now... I just go down this way. Flitter over here...
Bye bye, everybody!
Don't mind me!
Just a flying freak going through the sky.
Wait a minute, but how is this gonna help me--I ca- that doesn't make sense.
Ohh! I see, there's a shrubbery down there over to the right, so the bird was a red herring for now.
Like, I'll probably need it later, but right now I just need to be able to cross that bridge.
It's-it's just something to delay you, you go across that bridge and of course, you're gonna kill it
But now that it's dead you can scurry through the bushes here.
go over here...
I'm not big enough to eat you! Goddammit I thought I needed to- ugh I thought I needed to go on a diet. Goddammit.
Okay and then, habuski?
Theeeen
You can't hide from meee! Habuski
Alright
Then, ehhhhh
Okay
Nowww I need that bird, now I need that bird. Okay.
Now I need that bird which is right over here.
SORRY BUDDY
Okay now I got the bird
I'm good to go on that, I go over the-the chasm to the dude.
Eat the dude, become bigger bird and eat the cougar. Bam
Then I need to get SMAaall again
Hi, moutheth, gonna get BOTH of ya!
Okay, now that I got those,
I can finally go up the pathway to...
that lady who did NOT START A FIRE.
Man, she really shoulda started a fire, because that woulda saved her from all THIS.
*shock*
How did you get impaled by your own stick?!
It was a flimsy-ass stick.
And how did I do that?
I don't even know how I did that. "Hello?" "*snores*"
"I need your help." *scoff* Please...
"*snore" "Never mind."
Really?
Really??
Really???
Oh, really?
Oh, THAT'S how we're gonna go about this?
OH. If I'd known this game was gonna be..
so long...
I would... *whump attack* I would've done something else. I'll be right back.
Hokay. Hello, good bye.
Hello. HELLO. Oh, God, hello.
Ohh, God, hello, goodbye. Thank you!
Thank you for that.
Why-why didya do that? Why'dya reset me over here?
*Sassiplier activate* NOOoo! NOoOoOo!~
Ah, goddammit.
You suck.
Not you, too! No!
I'm almost dead.
Not you too!  OH MY GOD
This is re--endless death this whole way
NOOO AHHH
GOOD GOD
OH THANK GOODNESS
I can't even get to you!
Oh no I can get to you. Ok.
So that's a little saving grace
oh god AHHH oh god
I'm almost dead, I'm so close to death
Please let me live! AHH ok
Let me live please please!
Living-- oh no I went the wrong way.
oh no ehhhhhhh
hueghhhh ehhhhh
Ok I got a squirrel. I got-
I can find safety in the trees
Ok, so where did I see
a bite size creature?
Was a bite size cre-- Oh YES
YES VERY YES OK
So theoretically,
what was the next step up that I could do?
I can't eat a marmoset yet
Was it trough here? Was a bigger one over--
ohh the raccoons!
ah hahaha
Ok so I got the raccoons
and my--  Goddammit I DID NOT DO THAT
Ok that's gonna break, can't do that,
but now
I think I'm big enough to take you on maybe
I don't wanna  test that theory though
yeyyeughgh YAH
OH GOD IT'S NOT-- UGHHHH
You're too dumb get out-- AHH DON'T DO THAT!
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET BY! OH GOD!
STOP IT!
OH YOU SACKS OF SHIT!
FUCK YOU!
You're just a bunch of bullies!
That's all you are!
Man, nature's really ganging up on me this time
OH JUKED YA! AHH, FUCK OFF!
Ok so we need the scurrying for a little bit longer
Can't take on that guy yet
Can eat the raccoons but I don't think I get any bigger
Yeah I don't get any bigger
Why?
Ok is there something above that guy
that I need?
"Do I need to get smaller" is the question
I'm gonna assume that's a frick-- oh no!
AHHH UGHHH
STOP! I DON'T NEED TO GO THAT WAY!
'CAUSIN A RUCKUS
YOU'RE CAUSING A SCENE!
STOP! STOP BEING A DICK!
Ughh ok coming in for the KILL
OK GOT IT GOOD GOLLY
JUKED YA HEUGHHHH
OK AHHH
Ok this one is rough-
this one is super rough
Oh burb? Burb?
Ok got a burb
That's good, thems good eats
so now I just need to get a little bigger
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to do that..
Is there anything else here left to eat?
I can't eat those things
Ahh but I can get back and eat you!
Just a little bit bigger and eat the burb's over here
Hey burbs~ AND YOU! OH MY GOD!
That was a rough-- wow he became the tent!
He literally became all of tent-
good for him.
"I'm lost and can't find my friends. I think something terrible has happened."
"Them meteors.. Somethin ain't right. I saw one touch down. Swore somethin' crawled out."
"What?! We have to go then. It's not safe here."
"These are my woods. Nothing's gonna run me out of them."
"We need to find help. I'm outta here!"
Well you're gonna find death-
which is a damn shame because you seem like a nice guy.
Ok, so what's the first steps here?
I can't scurry through there so I can't get him.
Can't go there. Can't get that guy, can't eat him.
h-- oh whooo gotcha!
Ok so now that I got the scurrying ability everything should be much easier than that..
I could scurry though and get the water ability..
That would be nice, uh small, I'm already small.
That just means that I'm gonna have to circle back and get small again later,
but at least I can get this fish-
FOR NOW
Get-- come here you. Thank you. Sploosh!
Ok so there's another waterway-- whoooaa- over here
GET THE TURT
Ahh I can't eat the turt yet I need the big..
I need to "imbiggenate" myself.
Oh I can do that right-- ahh fuck you!
Hyah! Missed me~
DOINK. Okay.
Get you. Get YOU.
Get you.
And then go back this way.
So now that I've been embiggenated I can eat you.
Aaaaaand- AWWWW dang it, I needed the fish
or do I need the fish? Oh, I need the fish.
I need the fish! God damn it, I didn't mean to do that.
Now that I'm smaller again, I need to go back and literally- Oh, God, I gotta go get the fish again. Get that again.
*sings* I'm an idiot. Oh, I'm an idiot.
I'm an idiot, yeah, yeah, yeah. (10/10, winner of American Idol)
*groans* Okay. Here we go again.
Hehbeff
Okay. That goes straight up this way.
Hebleff. Noooo. HebLEFF.
HEBLEFF
Okay, now that we're big...
No, you're not givin' up. I'm not givin' this up.
So now...
NO. Stop that.
So now, I need the scurrying to go through here.
AMBUSH!
WHOA, GOT IT.
Okay, so now that I got this, I can just flap across, get the guy, and I'm DURN!
Ha! Heh, you shoulda- OH, NO!
*giggles* Oh, no. He got roasted on his own fire.
Ohh, there's something whimsical about this.
Why?
*unimpressed* Wow. Holy shit.
That's weird.
"Help me. There's something out here. I think my friends are dead!" (No SHIT, Sherlock)
"Listen, buddy. I only get two weekends off a year."
"Save your hysterical ravings for someone who cares. Now get lost so I can enjoy my very naked vacation."
*sexy Mark voice* It's the best way to celebrate life.
Okay, whatcha got for me?
So flyin' up there, water down there, big guy down there
This is gonna take some thunklin'.
I gotta thunkle up a storm, that's for damn sure. Okay.
I don't have the scurrying power.
Oh, that was a mistake- OHHHH, that was a red herring right off the bat.
You had a red herring ready for me.
Unless you didn't.
It looks like ya did.
DEAD! God damn... mice, they're so hard to grab.
Okay, so that's for later. I just gotta get 'em for later. But first...
I gotta go this way.
Through the... maze-type woods.
No, I don't need that guy.
Oh, yes, I do, because now I can get the flying. Get him.
Go up heyaaaaaaw. Heugh, go up heyaaw.
Stretch my butthole so I can a little... more SPEED goin'. (I don't think that's what buttholes are for)
Get the flappy floops, fly over here.
*concentration face* AHH, here we go. Flippity flop over here.
WHOA. Get you.
Can I eat you?
Aw, I can't eat you yet. No.
Need something-AAAOOH. No.
OHHHH, n- Oh, no. Oh, no.
Oh, no. I have just-
I just screwed up EVERYTHING.
I just screwed up absolutely everything. Oh, no, I didn't.
'Cuz now I can scurry.
That's good...
That's good. I can scurry now. I didn't screw up everything.
I did what I needed to do, hopefully?
So what I nee- YEEEES, I didn't.
God damn it, I didn't. Oh, wait, no, yes.
Be a little bigger...
Scurry...
Go through here... Hey, buddy, you wanna fight?
*chuckles* Oh, that-
Ya shouldn't have done that. Ya really-
Ya really shouldn't have done that.
Now I have the water power, go through here,
down here, all the way around..
I can't take him, but I can if I eat this big one here.
And then that'll be enou-oooOOOOkay.
Never mind, then. You're gonna throw me the wrong way because I'm a dummy.
Nope, not that way, but first go down here... here.
Go aROUND YOU- ah, shit.
Oh, how am I gonna- AW, fuck off with you!
Oh, no, wait, it was up here. Damn it, I thought it was over ther- *slain*
AHHH! NO, GOD DAMN IT! NO (X4)
Okay, now. Ah, there we go.
I swear I hit that button.
I swear I hit that button?
I swear I hit that button. (Sure)
I thought I did- oop, nope. I picked the one that was a dead end.
Good for me! I'm a big loser in front of everybody!
*cries slightly* EVERYBODY'S watching this and watching me be terrible at this.
GREEEEEEEAT!
Ohhhhhh, joyous day.
WELL! I don't see any difference.
I think everything's exactly as good as it once was, so we can just move on.
And, maybe this is gonna be the last one?
OH, it is.
"This cave is my only chance. If I can last until morning, I should be able to find my way back.
PLEASE, GOD, let me be safe."
Oh, I don't think so. I don't think so.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna blast through this last level and you're gonna get your ass eaten.
*Darkiplier emerges* From the inside out.
M'kay, where we startin?
Where we gonna start? *justice whumps from above* Oh, right here.
Good thing that bird didn't notice anything that's go-
OHHHH, God. EEH.
Oh, you're gonna be like that, huh?
Oh, that's how you're gonna play this, huh? Ah, geez. Okay.
Oh, goddamnit.
Heugh. Huch. HeeeeeUEUEUEUEUEGH, okay. (Mark, you okay?)
I'll come- There we go.
Ha-HA. HAHA! Ow, goddamnit.
Okay, we're fine. We're fine, everything's fine.
Everything is a hundred percent okay.
*everything becomes not okay* AHHH! Oh, God. Okay.
LOTS o' lethality on this one, cuz this is, probably, the last one.
My... GOODNESS, this level is big. (Oh, look at that sweet smile)
So, I get this squirrel, I imagine.
Errrrrrrererererer BOINK. Okay.
So now that I got the scurrying power, I can go up this-
Eeeeugh, this way. Okay. Go through here.
Get that thing, get a little bigger.
So now I'm bigger, and that was the first goal that I needed to accomplish, I bet.
And then, I get that bird, and  I'm gonna be able to fly...
further.
Er, at least I'll be able to fly to an area where I can actually eat something bigger than I was able to before.
Hopefully...
Oooh. Okay, if I fly down here now, maybe.
Yeah- OH, yeah.
And I'm a bigger scurrier. Now I'm here.
Okay,  then I can get that.
That's another scurrying beast. I don't need that right now.
Can't go down that way.
GET BAITED. Oh, get baited. Oh, and YOU...
are EATEN. Yeeees.
Yes.
Yes, now I have the power
Now I am the one who rules.
Okay, so- SPLOOSH. SHPLUMF.
Okay, SPLOOSH.
Then more... SCURRYIN' powah!
Go through heyaAAAAW.
Eat the BOID. Ah, now I'm a big boid.
Oh. *chuckles* Now you're...now everything gets eated.
Oh, is there any reason I should do that?
No, there's not.
Then I just keep goin'.
I sh- I shouldn't need to- unless I was just feelin' like it
but I feel like it'd ruin everything because it would give me scurrying powers
and I don't need that right now.
Where the heck's the dude- OHHhh, he was up here.
Oh, I didn't need to do any of that!
Wuh-hah..I just went on a REVENGE killing spree.
AHHHHH-OOOOH! Oh, man.
Well...
Not the worst one of them all, but..
That was a nice scream before then.
Hohhhh, GOD! *chuckles* Ohh, geeeeeeeez.
VICIOUS attacks.
Unlike ANYTHING we've ever seen.
*dramatic* Horrifying murders.
Well, there you have it! "The Visitor"...
Is back, and he's munchin' on some innards.
And it didn't take me too long.
It was a longer game, but actually I kinda liked it.
So, thank you, everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought of it,
and check out the other "Visitor" games that I've played down in the description below.
And as always, I will see you...
in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*cool outro music, bro*
[Song: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]